well he is the voice behind some of the
most romantic songs in music history and
now he's ready to romance fans in las
vegas mercedes started back it started
back at one i wanted to sing that with
brian mcknight ahead of his show tonight
check it out
[Music]
welcome back to the show brian mcknight
it's so great to have you back on las
vegas now how are you doing
i'm good i realize now that we it seems
like every six months five months or so
we're we're back doing this which means
i'm playing vegas again which is great
that means that last time was so
successful i was actually there and what
a show i mean
your voice is just
it just transcends i don't know how else
to explain it how do you keep that that
voice intact how do you take care of
yourself
well i think it's just what you said
it's important it's important that at
least for me
to
show up and sound the way people expect
me to sound um
i've spent 30 years
creating the idea that i sound
or at least i
i try to sound as good or better than
the records that you hear i know that a
lot of singers will do like vocal
exercises and things like that do you
have anything are you like
do you do anything like that
no
i don't
and i look everybody has their thing
that works out for them i just vocalize
there's a couple of songs
that i sing before uh before i go out
and do a show that aren't necessarily
even my songs that take me through
how much of my voice
i have available to me tonight there is
a
a stevie wonder song that he did with
tony bennett called for once in my life
it's got a lot of range it starts low it
ends high um there's a kenny loggins
song called heart to heart which tests
my falsetto how much my my falsetto i
have
[Music]
tonight the latest single faithfully
beautiful song
oh i i read somewhere that you said you
kind of faked it for a lot of your
career you didn't really truly you wrote
love songs but you didn't really know
that feeling it's faithfully is
faithfully about that feeling well yes
see every every song that i've written
since my wife leilani and i met has been
about her she's been the only subject
for the songs i've ever written
um before i met leilani i was basically
just
writing to write
so songs like anytime and back at one
and still and still in love those are
all songs that were born from basically
trying to write songs like other people
anybody can write songs but when it
comes from the heart you listen to the
the lyrics i've written say line and i
met there's a lot of forever there's a
lot of for always there's a lot of for
the rest of my lives and seeing unborn
children in your eyes that has never
been a part of any of those other songs
it's that there's definitely a lyrical
difference what is the first thing when
people see you in public that they say
to you do they do they recite a song
lyric do they
do they call you like oh the love song
because i i think about like if i ran
into you in person
i know exactly what i would say and i'm
wondering if you get it from everyone
else i would i would probably start
singing one
like a dream come true
so there's that uh it it really depends
sometimes it's hey do you know who you
look like it's funny because they don't
want to they would rather be wrong than
to look they'd rather be wrong than to
look stupid if they say are you brian
ignite i'm like no they're like oh that
was silly so it's very strange but
sometimes they do do that sometimes they
say hey do i ever cross your mind any
time i'm like oh you're the first person
that ever said that to me
well we're really looking forward to
having you back at the encore theater at
wynn uh if you haven't seen the show
before
it's just it's just beautiful it's like
a work of art you do such a great job on
it brian and your your 85 voice is 150
of my book
thank you thank you so much